police have arrested at least 50 people
in the south east of Iran after
protesters attacked Banks and
demonstrated against the government the
demonstrations continue in the country
five weeks after the death of a woman in
police custody that sparked public
outrage meanwhile Iranians outside the
country are calling on Western Nations
to do more to help and to ensure the
safety of those arrested
the latest adoption of anger in Iran
in footage recorded on Friday hundreds
of angry protesters in the city of
zahedan chant death to the dictator in
reference to Ayatollah Khomeini the
Islamic Republic's leader
the wave of public descent gripping Iran
in the wake of the death of jeena mahasa
amini violent police custody is highly
unusual in this footage from the capital
Tehran a man has climbed a billboard to
spray graffiti the ad says the Earth
Bears Gold
he is writing and cleric steal the gold
Iranian voices outside the country like
the National Council of resistance of
Iran have been stepping up their own
protests such as this one in Brussels
close to where EU leaders were holding a
two-day Summit
you're asking that the European
community and the European Union
their tone towards Israel Iranian
regime change they don't want any
appeasement with this regime in an
address to the U.N security Council this
week the U.S made its nuclear the eyes
of the entire world are on Iran right
now
courageous and brave Iranians from
across Society women and men are
protesting the death of Masa Amiri
they are protesting the fact that she
was killed by the Iranian morality
police for the crime of being a woman
but Iran has warned Western governments
not to interfere
Iranian women are smart well educated
dedicated and patriotic and or aware of
their rights they also understand how to
engage with the government in a peaceful
and constructive manner in order to
advance their rights
therefore we advise those western states
that they are not required to act as
guardians or caretakers of Iranian women
or speak on their behalf
yet speak on their behalf is what many
of those protesting want given the scale
of the challenge they face in standing
up to the autocracy which has ruled
their country for more than 40 years
by joining me now in studio is Sima
sabachis a presenter and reporter with
Iran International television thanks for
joining us here on DW news as we saw in
that report you know the protests have
been going on for weeks now
um this is unusual in Iran
um what do you think is giving people
this courage to come out on the streets
and protest like they are human dignity
the the main chanting has been woman
like freedom so I think this was the
time that people felt that enough is
enough like killing a 22 years old girl
on holiday in Tehran just because she
was not covered properly
unacceptable this was something that
every single Iranian family could relate
to and finally there was a moment that
stated like I mean everyone was
extremely frustrated extremely angry and
this feeling like that 22 years old was
beaten to death and then the
government's light brought extreme anger
amongst people so everyone took to the
street it started from the courtesan
like Kurdish populated areas that muscle
came originally from and then The
Bravery came from the family because
they were not intimidated by the
pressures that they were getting from
the security forces and The Bravery of
the journalists who they went they dared
to go and cover it nilo for comedy the
journalists who covered the story at the
hospital at Kestrel Hospital in Tehran
she is still in prison she's arrested
family don't know what is happening to
her under interrogation but she was
Brave to do it yeah and you're talking
about this issue of even the truth of
the story and how to even get that out
journalists are at the Forefront but
obviously under severe restrictions in
Iran how is this story actually being
covered in the local media are they
having the the will or the the room to
be able to cover it but the outside
media have like a little bit more
freedom in terms of like reporting it
with shutdown of Internet we have had
like Iran International is one of them
be happy on this story for weeks
um
non-stop reporting on that yesterday uh
they announced that I mean they put like
Islamic Republic put BBC and Iran
International under sanctions today I
heard one of the judiciaries wanted the
journalists to be listed as terrorist
groups so this is this is how they try
to intimidate people covering it and
inside also there has been like massive
bravery amongst journalists everyone is
trying to do their parts inside and
outside yeah and speaking of inside and
outside we've got the protests in Iran
but we've also got protests abroad yes
how are these being seen the
international condemnation of what's
going on has that been seen particularly
by the regime well of course they're not
happy with it because I mean there is
finally bits of Truth are coming outside
finally people are listening to the to
the like um
grief of Iranians and this sense of
unity is that we see inside Iran inside
Iran I mean there were always like um
these sort of things that I mean the
government was saying that if I'm not
there there would be internal world if
I'm not there there will be lack of
Securities etc etc now you can see that
people inside Iran are like I mean
different sections of Iran are
supporting each other inside and outside
you see the mass demonstration that was
in Toronto we will have something today
the organizers are expecting like more
than 100 thousands to participate so
these two are covering everyone every
Iranian tries to do something anything
that they can all right journalists
thank you for your analysis on the story
thank you